And you know,
you go into places like that,
I always think of the archetypal diner
in that way.
You know,
you guys have been in this diner,
there's a really good opposite diner and
there's a great video on youtube.
It's Tom waits reading,
reading a poem by Makowsky and I think
it's called Nirvana.
And it's about a good diner that,
that happened to visit because he
happened to visit when he was on a bus
when he was a,
when he was a kid,
a diner where everything was going well.
And you could listen to that.
It's great.
I think it's great.
But this is the opposite diner I'm
thinking about.
So you'll go into a diner,
right?
It's 7:00
in the morning and you order some bacon
and eggs and some toast and then you
look around in the diner and you think
it was like 1975 when the windows were
last washed.
And there's this kind of thick coating
of who gives a damn grease on the walls,
you know,
and,
and the floor to has got that sort of
stickiness that you really have to work
out to develop over years,
you know,
and the waitress is,
she's not happy to be there and the guy
behind the counter isn't happy that,
that happens to be the waitress that
he's working with.
And then,
you know,
you walk down the stairs maybe to the
washroom and now it's its own little
trip and so you come back and you order
your damn eggs and you order your toast
in the order your bacon and then it
comes in like the eggs are too cooked on
the bottom.
So they're kind of brown and then
they're kind of raw on top and they're
cold in the middle,
which is,
you really have to work their cooking
egg like that man.
But you can master that with like 10
years of bitterness.
You teach you how to cook an egg like
that.
And then the toast,
here's what you do with the toast,
right?
You put,
you take,
you take the white bread,
you know the precise stuff that no one
should ever eat and then you put that in
the toaster and you overcook it and then
you wait and then you pop it out of the
toaster and then cause it's overcooked.
You scrape it off and you knock off the
crumbs so it doesn't look too bird and
then you wait till it's cold and then
you put cold margin on it because if you
put cold march,
first of all,
not butter,
but if you put cold margarine or you can
also kind of tear holes in it so then it
has lumps of margarine in it and it's
really dry except where it's too greasy.
So that's like it's own little work of
art man.
And then you put that on the side with
the,
with the,
with the eggs and then you have the
potatoes and this is how you cook the
potatoes properly.
So the leftover potatoes and you keep
dumping new leftover potatoes into the
old leftover potatoes over weeks.
And so some of the potatoes,
if they're no longer potatoes,
right?
They've have return to mother earth,
then you flop them on the grill and you
sort of had to know you burned them a
bit I guess,
and then you slap them on the plate and
Jesus,
you don't want to eat those man.
That's for sure.
And that's the point.
And then you have the bake and then you
want to make sure you buy the lowest
possible quality bacon.
That's how I start.
And then you throw it on the grill and
you don't.
Your grill has to be overheated to do
this,
you have to cook the Bacon so that it's
raw and places and burnt in other places
and it has that delightful like older.
They'd only really cheap,
badly cooked bacon can provide or maybe
you use those little breakfast sausages
that no one in their bloody right mind
would let within 15 feet of anything
living,
you know.
And then you serve that right and you
serve it with the kind of orange juice
that is only orange in color and,
and with coffee,
that's.
What would you say it was started too
early in the morning.
That's the first thing.
Bad quality coffee started too early in
the morning route.
God called once or twice and has been
reheated,
and then you serve that with whitener.
It's like,
here is your breakfast.
no man,
that's not breakfast.
That's hell
no,
and and you created it and then what you
do if you have a diner like that is
because you have a miserable life.
If you have a diner like that and you've
really worked on achieving that is every
night you go home and you curse your
wife and you curse your kids and you
fucking well curse God to for producing
a universe where a diner like yours is
allowed to exist and that's your bloody
life.